[Musique]
quartier des olives 13e arrondissement
de marseille ce soir cette bande de
potes fait l'enterrement de vie de
garçon d'olivier une soirée surprise
organisée par julien le témoin du marié
la voisine qui est sentie et au lieu de
nous bien trop de bois c'est magnifique
c'est merveilleux
mon quartier
connaître
les jarrets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
julien est français d'origine arménienne
comme ses parents tous sont nés à
marseille ce sont ses grands parents qui
ont fuit la turquie et le génocide de
leur peuple en 1915 plus d'un million et
demi d'arméniens n'ont pas eu cette
chance comme le veut la tradition
arménienne il faut un moment donné aussi
se souvenir chever je voudrais le voir à
toutes les personnes de nos familles qui
sommes plus là aujourd'hui pensez à ceux
qui un jour se sont soulevés on dit que
ça suffisait et qu'il fallait simplement
se révolter je crois qu'on est tous
issus de cette frange là on vient tous
un peu de ce terreau là et que tant bien
que mal on essaie de le perpétuer très
attachés à leurs racines julien ses amis
appartiennent à une troupe folklorique
amateurs les chants et la danse
impossible de s'en passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup se plaire
c'est joyeux ya cet expert la chose
faite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain julien rendez vous à
l'église apostolique de marseille
dirigeant de la jeunesse arménienne de
france il les convie avec toute la
communauté a inauguré le centre culturel
pour cette grande occasion le prélat
numéro deux de l'église apostolique
s'est déplacé pour la bénédiction
d importance inauguration parce que
c'est là mais c'est une deuxième corde
et maisons de l'arménité promène
inauguré un apprenti 500 questions c'est
cela tu voyais je vais la communauté
arménienne de marseille
est la plus de
trois
ans novembre 23 ans
parfaitement c'est la dernière rescapée
depuis 95 ans ceux qui continuent de
souder la diaspora c'est le génocide
arménien
sa famille du côté de sa mère a été plus
je veux me préserver mais tu comptes et
ne semble pas pas ils ont tous les
personnages ont tous été assez reprises
ok cheville puis 5e
auquel jonnier et avant l'important
c'est la touche est tellement bien
entendu plus il ya une quinzaine
d'heures il ya plus personne témoigner
je suis obligé de raconter mois
total record de
soutenir quelqu'un telle entame
négationnisme c'était
à ce jour si la france et l'onu ont
reconnu le génocide arménien la turquie
elle refuse toujours de l'admettre
pourtant en france aucune loin de
condamner le négationnisme turc c'est le
combat de julien les arméniens de
diaspora en deux ans ça en eux qu'ils
aient fait que le génocide constitue la
pierre angulaire vraiment de tout news
et pour cause si on est ici soit vis ici
c'est parce qu'on a été victime d'un
génocide
et c'est comme ça qu'on est arrivé là un
peu malgré nous on n'a pas choisi l'armé
net qui vit là bas il n'a plus un
problème de savoir surtout comment
dessus en ville une voiture alors y
tenons d'abord né dans la mémoire et
puis on est aussi dans 80 il pour la
reconnaissance du génocide arbres
jour d'hui les arméniens de marseille
sont à paris julien et sa troupe de
danse ont rendez vous sur les planches
d'un grand théâtre pour la dernière de
leur comédie musicale ars a rate mon
amour et voir les films
et les filles well et belle-fille date
mon amour
la salle est comble les corps
s'échauffent et la pression monte
[Applaudissements]
julien entre en scène un peu plus tard
ils assistent des coulisses au début du
spectacle
l'histoire de deux jeunes frères
arméniens séparés lors du génocide
le débordement sellem de fondamental
faut cultiver cet homme est mort là
et par ce spectacle retransmis ses
devoirs de mémoire là
on sensibilise
l'opinion publique à ce travail de
mémoire là que nécessaire pour éviter
justement que ça se reproduise et là ça
va démarrer
[Musique]
et là coup c'est l'explosion
sur les planches les danses se succèdent
et l'ambiance bascule des coulisses
julien vis l'un des moments clés du
spectacle la scène du massacre
[Musique]
je n'ai aussi n'est toujours pas
reconnue par la turquie
on encore
rien faire
les sens
rires cette sépulture en morale à tout
ce qu'ils sont
[Musique]
nos parents qu'ils ont péri dans la nuit
si aujourd'hui son nom
je
pour rien
c'est enfin l'heure de la renaissance et
l'entrée en scène de julien pas de
stress pour lui ils dansent depuis plus
de 20 ans
[Musique]
mission accomplie pour la troupe c'est
un triomphe enfin et comme pour chaque
marseillais qui se respecte la victoire
se fait en chantant
[Applaudissements]
tu viens de remporter des victoires tu
passes salle owens et des barres jours
c'est ça la double dutch